David thanks for joining us good morning
how are you you got a man how you doing
I'm doing okay let me start with Alex
Smith with what you saw last night will
we consider that offense from a
quarterbacking perspective of what you
saw and is that something that we might
be seeing the rest of the season with
the Chiefs well I think that what Andy
Reid has done is taking a West Coast
offense and kind of kind of put some
tweaks to it they had some gadget plays
with Tyree killing the backfield very
solid a nice toss but you know they're
running some speed options with Alex
Smith which is kind of crazy they do
some they do some interesting things I
mean they used Travis Kelce at
quarterback with Alex Smith at the
tailback position on a second in one
place so I mean they got a lot of time
on their hands it seems like and the one
thing that you have you heard throughout
the entire offseason was we need to get
more big plays out Alex and it wasn't
just from the fans in the media but it
was from the coaching staff and you
heard it when they were talking in the
preseason games and Patrick mahomes
comes in and he's making big plays down
the field
so there's stalkers well maybe you
should be the guy and for the first half
we're sitting in there and we're
watching the game together and I was all
with all the guys doing the show and
we're thinking and he doesn't look
comfortable yet or getting some plays
they're moving the football but he's
gonna have to play better in the second
half and he comes out in the second half
and he's throwing the football down the
field times past people he's he made
some big plays in that offense and
that's what people have wanted really
since they lost in the playoffs
they've been looking for that from him
and so if he can continue to do that
push the football down the field not be
not be hesitant I mean they can be a
really good football team so you know
from Alex's standpoint I played with him
in San Francisco a year I know he's
mentally tough I know he's going to be
able to kind of hold Patrick Manzana fit
and go out there and do this thing but
you know it's one thing he's been tough
it's another thing to have the ability
to go out there and actually execute the
plays you have to execute and he did
that last night and I was I was super
happy for him I think that was what he
needs to do if you can continue to do
that the Chiefs are going to be
something scary but I also look at this
and I don't overreact to what
saw last night I want to know what what
are we going to continue to see from
both of these teams and that's where I
look at New England and I say they have
new weapons they're on offense and
defense and it'll take time for them to
get acclimated to the Patriot way but
the defense look like it could be a
concern only because they didn't put any
pressure on the quarterback they didn't
they didn't put pressure on Alex Smith
as much as as they should and I don't
carry who you have in the secondary if
you're not gonna put pressure on a
quarterback and he's got weapons like
that then you're gonna get burned and
they got burned last night explain what
you saw with the Patriots defense and is
it just last night or is it something to
keep an eye on the rest of the year well
you know I mean Kansas City does some
look just like what we talked about
earlier they do some interesting things
on off the side of all that kid that can
put you in position on the defensive
side to where you're not as aggressive
and you can't really pin your ear back
your ears back and go get the
quarterback we saw last year with Kansas
City you know on third downs they got
pressured the least out of any team in
the entire league and and that's what
you kind of saw it in England and
Hightower went out think about talk
about all those young guys would young
guys but the new guys they have on that
field I mean you got some guys in the
secondary yes that have been there
before but Gil Horne hasn't you know he
can he made a play last night where
Tyree Childers runs right past him
that's a simple covered year I think he
wasn't expecting he was expecting help
back there so he's either got to get his
tail out of there and get deep with his
best or I got to play better defense and
then so Hightower leaves and you see huh
take advantage of you know some coverage
errors in the middle of the field a big
pass play down the middle there's just
some things that Kansas City does unique
unto themselves that makes it very
difficult to line up and then you kind
of couple that with the fact that they
don't have a lot of continuity on the
defensive side of the ball yet and you
can see some big plays you saw some in
the run game you saw some some edges not
set you know I'm sitting up there with
Marcus we're in Houston you know they're
not setting the edges and I said and
continuously guys getting to the
perimeter so you fellow checkers he's
gonna be livid in the defense meeting
that just doesn't happen at me soon
Willie McGinest is not walking through
the door so they're gonna have to figure
something out they have to get these
guys to start playing better but it is
you don't want to overreact and that's
usually what we do in these situations
but it's gonna take some time for those
guys to gel they're definitely gonna be
there at the end of this thing I mean
they're they're good football team on
the other side of the ball they have
talent obviously maybe as much as
they've had in a long time but they're
gonna have to have to work through some
things you heard Tom Brady talk about we
need competitive guys they got a beat
that their attitude has to be correct
it's all it's all a learning process for
these guys because there's a lot of
different ball players that are trying
to gel and it just doesn't happen
yeah it's gonna take time and that's why
I tell people I caution that you know
you can look at them and say they're
gonna be great but they're gonna have
hiccups they can have those bad nights
but then you're gonna have to say you
know with that that talent they're going
to somehow regroup but it's week to week
and the NFL is you know better than
anybody I do want to ask you this before
I let you go and that is DeSean Kaiser
gets the start in Cleveland can you give
us a sense of what that feel can you
take us back you know when you were
starting and a rookie and what you think
DeSean Kaiser is going to be feeling
facing when he faces the Steelers well I
mean first of all someone told me that
an idea was 15 years ago to the day that
I played against the Cowboys in my own I
said 15 years why don't you guys make
him you make me feel really old but so
that was my first start was against the
Dallas Cowboys
we look at all these young guys that
have come out this year a lot of hype a
lot of these guys but DeSean don't want
started so he's going out there I know
obviously like you said firsthand the
kind of pressure that he's gonna be
under he doesn't know that he doesn't
know at this point it really doesn't and
there's a lot of things that you're
gonna have to just work through he's
he's a talented guy he's the most
talented guy you know in their training
camp and that's that's kind of what
happened to me we had Kent Grant was
there but he was struggling through some
back issues he was at the end of his
career we had a couple other young guys
it worked out that you know I just I
just made more plays in training camp
and it was kind of hard for them to keep
me off the field and I think the same
thing is happening with DeSean and
Cleveland is he just he just looks
better than everybody else I mean he's
physically has it and but the only thing
that he doesn't have he doesn't have any
experience and I saw I'm a little
hesitant about putting out there until
you look at through the head coaches and
I know we talked about Hugh Jackson a
lot but really there's probably only
three or four other guys that I would
take is a play caller over him you look
at what has happened in Cincinnati
she left it hasn't been good and they
still have the same talent you know the
same guys running around there and any
Dalton's still there playing quarterback
but the record has not been the same the
efficiency hasn't been the same so I
think that if I'm gonna put the Shan out
in that situation where he doesn't
really understand what's happening he's
got a lot of physical tools he's gonna
work through some stuff Hugh Jackson's
the guy that I would want calling the
place for me and he can do some things
to protect the quarterback I'm gonna do
a lot of shifts and motions and kind of
what kind of what we saw Kansas City do
to New England is you put them in
positions where they're they're a little
bit on their heels on the defensive side
of the ball and that's what you can do
for a play for a quarterback so that's
kind of what I'm looking forward to I
think that I think DeSean is gonna be a
good quarterback I think they have some
some pieces there in Cleveland they're
starting to build something but you know
I mean he's in good hands I'll
definitely say that I think the Shawn
just go out there continue to grow and
at some point your team is going to be
ready to play and maybe that's crazy to
say maybe Cleveland will never be ready
I like to think that with you there
they'll be ready to go and do something
productive and he just has to be ready
and that's what I told Derek when he
came out they weren't very good their
first year but at some point your team
is gonna be ready and they are now in
Oakland and and you got to be ready to
go out there to lead them and that's
what the Shawn has to do he's David Carr
the NFL Network analyst if we had a
fantasy draft and you had you had to
take a quarterback all quarterbacks are
available who you takin okay let me just
tell you what happened okay so we have
we have a fantasy a little fantasy
league amongst our family and friends so
it's mine
everybody in their right minds brother
and the first pick you know we was my
brother Derek which I thought I raised
some eyebrows oh yeah I didn't pick him
now I won't say who did but I thought
that was a little high for Derek but uh
you know they didn't and they went and
grabbed him
so in our league he went first which
which I was totally fine with because I
got David Johnson the third pick but
yeah if I had to pick one guy I mean
it's hard to really pick against Aaron
Rodgers and when I look at I look at
their team this year
there's quickly a Martellus Bennett
coming in there helping them is gonna do
so much for the run game that it's going
to make it a little bit easier for Aaron
and that's the one thing you don't want
to see so what you're saying is your
brother is overrated
that's this just in David cars is that
accurate
first overall David yeah he shouldn't be
the first quarterback taken well there's
only one of those in our family that's
what I've kind of course number one
overall favorite yes a great to talk to
you good luck this season and we'll
hopefully touch base again for sure
thanks dude
that's David Carr NFL Network analyst
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience